كنا نراه الآن أمرًا من
الواضح أنه مزعج
ما لا يقل عن 19 ولاية تشهد الآن
زيادة في حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا ، ربما نحتاج
إلى الإبطاء قليلاً ، ربما نحتاج إلى
الانتظار 10 تكثيف قدراتنا
لتحديد تتبع جهة اتصال معزولة لا
نريدها  للخروج عن السيطرة مرة أخرى ، يصدر مركز السيطرة على
الأمراض الآن تحذيرًا جديدًا بأن الوقت الذي
يقضيه مع الآخرين يزيد بشكل كبير
من خطر الإصابة بالفيروس ، وكلما زاد
عدد الأشخاص المشاركين في
التفاعل ، كلما زاد خطر انتشار كوفات
19 ، تعمل أركنساس الآن على تنشيط
الحرس الوطني  الأعضاء بعد رؤية
عدد قياسي من الحالات في الـ 24
ساعة الماضية ، قمنا بزيادة 731 حالة في
الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
، تضغط الآن العديد من الولايات والمدن في جميع أنحاء أمريكا
على إيقاف مؤقت لإعادة الفتح ، فأنا
أكثر مما يرغب أي شخص تقريبًا في
القول إن مدينة بالتيمور هي  مفتوح وآمن
ولكن هذا ليس ما
تخبرنا به البيانات في هذا الوقت على الرغم من
الزيادة الطفيفة في بعض الولايات مثل إنديانا
لا تزال تمضي قدمًا.
لكي يكون Hoosiers آمنًا بينما ننتقل إلى
المرحلة الرابعة ، أشعر وكأنني أم مزعجة قليلاً ،
لكنني سأذكرك أن
kovat لم يختف وأنه
يضيء حركة الكاميرا في جورجيا
وكاليفورنيا مع الأفلام والتلفزيون الذي
بدأ الإنتاج في
واشنطن أنا كارين كيفا